und wir haben jetzt die seltene
gelegenheit meine damen und herren
exklusiv mit einem mann zu sprechen der
putin sehr gut kennt michael kasjanow
war von 2000 bis 2004 russische
ministerpräsident also während putins
erster amtszeit als präsident der galt
als liberal kritisierte die festnahme
von regime gegnern wie michail
chodorkowski wurde daraufhin von putin
entlassen und selbst zum oppositionellen
der auch morddrohungen bekommen hat nach
der russischen einnahme der krim hat
kassian auf dem westen geraten hart
gegen putin zu sein ansonsten würde man
später einen viel höheren preis bezahlen
müssen und genau so ist es gekommen aus
sicherheitsgründen sagen wir nicht von
wo er uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist guten
tag herr kasjanow
der kaserne auf derwesten hat putin ganz
offensichtlich falsch eingeschätzt sie
haben mit ihm gearbeitet sie kennen ihn
ganz genau wie weit wird er noch gehen
wie wird er reagieren wenn er weiterhin
nicht vorankommt wie geplant wie
cholerisch wie wütend wie unberechenbar
kann er werden
18 jahren
insofern ist das jetzt kann ich andere
putin ein anderes nicht aber es könnte
den ich damals kannte war jemand der
demokratische und liberale reformen auch
in der wirtschaft mitgetragen wird
unterstützt hat die mine kabinett
angestoßen ganz lange zeit und der
routing hat praktisch alle versprechen
damals umgesetzt außer einem der
gassektor wurde nicht reformiere die kas
durfte ich damals nicht reformieren das
war nicht erwünschte ich deswegen ist
dieser monopolist geblieben und diese
monopolisten als waffe eingesetzt und wo
putin jetzt noch fähig ist ja wir sehen
es jetzt er selber diese nachrichten die
wir gesehen haben seine erklärungen
sprechen bände
ich sehe immer mit kein ende dieses
krieges und diese verhandlungen die
jetzt laufen da scheint es ja es gibt
positive erwartungen aber ich glaube da
nicht das ist da sehr bald positive
ergebnisse geben kann aus einem grund
putin braucht den krisen ist aber
braucht den sieg und ein neutraler
status ist kein sieg er braucht die
anerkennung der krim die ukraine werden
das nie anerkennen dass die krippe mal
so groß ist dass russland unter putin
braucht auch die anerkennung der
unabhängigkeit und auch im endeffekt den
anschluss der don was territorien
russland insofern bin ich überzeugt
davon dass die ukraine den ii zustimmen
werden und so fährt kann ich keine
positiven ergebnisse erwarten von diesen
verhandlungen würde putin auch einen
krieg mit der nato und damit letztlich
einen weltkrieg riskieren
nun zunächst sehen sie ja dass alle
westlichen länder
alle nato bündnispartner sicht ist mit
großen mit großer besorgnis in bezug auf
die eigene unterstützung der ukraine
geäußert haben und diesen dieser faktor
führt auch dazu dass er weitermacht
protein und weiter seine angriffs
offensive führte ich glaube das ist
nicht die richtige haltung nicht ganz
die richtige haltung der westlichen
staaten im bezug auf die ukraine die
waffenlieferung müssen fortgesetzt
werden und es müssen die waffen
geliefert werden die den himmel zu
schützen eine flugverbots wäre natürlich
die beste lösung aber sicherlich gibt es
da eine risiken ich glaube allerdings
dass diesem spiel die westlichen staaten
wirklich
diesen schritt vornehmen sollten eine
flugverbotszone würde eben dazu führen
dass putin echt angst davor hätte das zu
verletzen gibt es eine realistische
chance dass er vom eigenen militär oder
von oligarchen kalt gestellt wird wenn
die sehen dass dieser krieg nicht zu
gewinnen ist und putin sie und das land
in den abgrund reißt
das ist eine fehlerhafte eine absolut
fehlerhafte meinung dass die oligarchen
überhaupt noch einfluss nehmen können
also wenn sie alle leute oligarchen ende
dann verstehe ich das ja eher so dass
das reichen leute sind die erzieher
videos überführung haben aber diejenigen
die reichen die militär geworden sind
damals in den 90er jahren haben
überhaupt keinen einfluss auf
beziehungen mit ihnen er die dann unter
putin wie sie sich entwickelt haben die
niemand einen nobody gewinnen und dann
millionäre geworden sind die sind ihm
gehörig sieht neben befehle entgegen
aber beeinflussen ich nicht insofern ist
diese
wahrnehmung fleisch die oligarchen
können ihn nicht beeinflussen und auch
nicht den krieg beenden und auch aus dem
militär könnte keinen widerstand kommt
gibt es keinen einzigen moment der
wirklich zu entschlossenen tätigkeiten
bis bereit wäre der noch nicht mal
bereit wäre klare worte zu wählen oder
zweifel gegenüber mutiges politik
vorzubringen solche militärs gibt es
nicht wie lange kann russland
wirtschaftlich noch durchhalten
das ist eine ernsthafte frage und die
steht tatsächlich auf der tagesordnung
jahr putin hat sich geirrt
er hat sich gehört weil er der meinung
war und das hat eben sein umfeld immer
wieder gesagt dass die reaktion des
westens
vergleichbar wäre wie damals im jahr
2014 oder nicht 2008 ich möchte sie nur
daran erinnern dass der westen natürlich
auch gewisser weise schuld trägt 2008
beispielsweise gab es den nato gipfel in
bukarest
die ukraine moldova und
georgien hatten den sogenannten map den
membership action plan
beantragte als perspektive für die
naturaufnahmen sie wissen damals wie das
wort deutschland unter anderem hat
dagegen gestimmt hat diese möglichkeiten
diesen ländern verwehrt diesen drei
ländern das überhaupt eine nach der
perspektive
und danach innerhalb von drei monaten
wissen sie ja bis die provokation in
georgien die georgische führung wurde
durch russland profi provoziert und dann
kam es zu diesem einmarsch in die rohre
geben das heißt dieser souveräne staat
georgen mutter angegriffen und danach
nach dem russland keinerlei punkte
erfüllt hat in bezug auf die waffenruhe
auf den waffenstillstand zwei monate
lang hat das gedauert und kaum man diese
drei monate vergangen hat der westen
bietet die seine
zusammenarbeit wieder aufgenommen
business as usual und da hat er gedacht
man ich komme ja mit allem davon mir
geht alles durch das der westen offenbar
das völkerrecht so interpretiert und
auch sehr wachen verletzt und was haben
wir danach bekommt die annexion der
queen 2000 fielen dann den krieg in
dombach und auch da gab es keine
reaktion keine ausreichende reaktion des
westens wurde nicht gestoppt und das hat
gut ihm freie hand gegeben
und deswegen ist er davon ausgegangen
dass die reaktion diesmal genauso sein
wird wir 2014 ist aber anders die
einheit die einigkeit der europäischen
union von der transatlantischen partner
hat putin verwundert und wirklich
schockiert ist eine ganze mannschaft
schlug fehl die sanktionen die jetzt
überhaupt das erste mal verhängt wurden
sehen wie zum beispiel das einfrieren
der finanzpresse zentralbank
beispielsweise ist ein extrem schwerer
schlag gegen die finanzwelt gegen die
wirtschaft 400 aus unserer firmen sind
schon aus dem land heraus sie nicht mehr
täglich ungefähr 200.000 menschen werden
dadurch ihre arbeit verlieren in den
nächsten drei monaten
ja und ich glaube
die sanktionen werden eine wirkung haben
die alle rosen merken die nächsten
monaten die wirtschaft wird weiter
schrumpfen
selbst die vorsichtigsten prognosen dass
das das budget um zehn prozent zurück
geht in diesem jahr das ist
gleichbedeutend mit den neunzigerjahren
was die wirtschaftsleitung geht
bereits jetzt fallen ja seit acht jahren
die realen einkommen der bevölkerung
jetzt fallen sie einfach katastrophal
es war vor allem angela merkel die gegen
den nato-beitritt der ukraine damals war
weil sie glaubte putin nicht provozieren
zu wollen und stattdessen auf dialog
setzte sie hat sich getäuscht er fährt
die mehrheit der russen tatsächlich
nicht dass dies keine militärische
sondern operation sondern ein brutaler
feldzug gegen die ukraine ist bei der
auch frauen und kinder sterben
russland wissen dass die leute die das
wissen wollen aber es gibt da nur noch
ein teil der bevölkerung
das hat man so das russische volk des
mutig folgte nur der propaganda lauf sie
wollen doch gar nichts anderes wissen im
sinn die gehirne gewaschen worden den
ersten jahren effektiv und auch sehr
hart und total immer wieder wurde der
putin sicht die putin sichtweise überall
durchgedrückte sie glauben daran dass
der westen die feinde sind und diese
propaganda ist wirklich extrem gewesen
in den letzten jahren und das sind leute
die wollen einfach nichts wissen aber
ich bin überzeugt davon dass mehrheit
der russen gegen den krieg und sie sind
einfach erstaunt was jetzt auf einmal
passiert einerseits man sich in der
vergangenheit neutral gegenüber putin
haben gut verdient und die sind extrem
schockiert weil das was jetzt passiert
vollkommen unberechenbar gewesen sie
wissen nicht wie es weitergehen soll sie
sehen dass die wirtschaft zusammenbricht
und das wird so wahnsinnig schnell uns
das sind wirklich leute die absolut
verzweifelt sind die wissen nicht wie es
weitergeht
welche möglichkeiten haben sie als
oppositioneller und regimekritiker ihren
landsleuten die wahrheit zu sagen und zu
zeigen
na ja ich
mache das immer wieder ich berichte
darüber lustig dass beispielsweise die
unterschiedlichen die sozialen medien
werden jetzt geschlossen ich bin jetzt
außerhalb von russland deswegen weiß ich
nicht ob man mich über twitter und
facebook noch lesen oder sehen kann aber
ich versuche natürlich immer wieder
kommentare zu veröffentlichen zu
bewerten was vorgebe und auch die
aktivitäten die handlungen von putin zu
analysieren und danach stellen
fertigkeit mit zu teilen auch seines
umfeldes in bezug auf das was jetzt
passiert bezug auf die ukraine in bezug
auf die sanktion also alles was im
moment so problematisch ich versuche ich
natürlich meine sichtweise total
natürlich ist der putin sehr in dem
moment gerade was er jetzt vor zwei
tagen gesagt hat als er mit den
wirtschaftsexperten gesprochen hat über
den rettungsplan des landes da hat man
gesehen dass niemand weiß wie es
weitergehen soll alle sind schockiert
keiner hat eine perspektive und man
versucht irgendwie das aus der
vergangenheit wieder zu beleben aber das
hilft nicht das wird die wirtschaft
nicht mehr helfen unter solchen
sanktionen unter diesem satz in puncto
kann er und seine leute nichts mehr
anfangen es gibt zwar immer noch
restliches geld was ins land kommen weil
deutschland und andere länder der
europäischen union natürlich weiterhin
erdgas kauften und hoffnung dafür
bezahlen also dieses geld kommt wieder
nach russland und wenn man so will ist
das der einzige finanzstrom die es im
moment noch gibt der den rubel
unterstützt innerhalb von fünf tagen hat
der ruf 40 prozent seines wertes
verloren jetzt ist er mehr oder weniger
stabil weil die zentralbank die
möglichkeit hat ihnen jetzt erstmal zu
stützen bei deutschland diese
finanziellen leistet und das unterstützt
in rufe sobald deutschland den kauf
dieser ressourcen des gases zurückfindet
wird der rubel weiter abstützen letzte
frage herr kassieren auf welchen
gefahren sind sie selbst ausgesetzt wenn
sie putin so offen kritisieren sie haben
schon morddrohungen bekommen unter
anderem von dem tschetschenischen
diktator kadyrow auf einen vasallen von
putin
lucia di maria den letzten jahren stand
ich natürlich immer unter druck selbst
auch unter physischen druck
aber
zumindestens ist es so dass sich in den
letzten tagen eigentlich immer hin
im ausland gelebt habe und habe auch in
der öffentlichkeit nicht meine meinung
zurückgehalten über das was gut tut wie
er in seinem mitgeführten und dem land
umgehen in der zwischenzeit sitten aber
gesetzesänderungen verabschiedet ordnung
kritik ist heutzutage ein
straftatbestand von ausland da gibt es
sogar einen artikel der bis zu 15 jahre
haftstrafe vorsieht wenn jemand sich
kritisch äußert und das ist natürlich
wenn man sich der beginn der
repressalien unterstützen bin ich als
übungsleiter aus gereist weil ich diese
risiken gar nicht mehr eingekriegt
gegenüber mir und meiner familie
deswegen bin ich jetzt auch in einem
europäischen land und das was jetzt
passiert und das hat ja putin auch vor
den letzten paar tagen vor drei tagen
gesagt wir sind national vertrete die
gesellschaft muss gesäubert werden das
erinnert mich sehr an eine geschichte
nicht nur in der sowjetunion sondern
geschichte die auch in deutschland
stattgefunden hat schreckliche tat
mussten repressalien durch die
säuberungen der opposition angekündigt
der kaserne auf ganz herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch und für diese sehr
offenen worte danke schön
vielen dank wo ich immer sehr gern bei
vielen dank